ندخل اكثر في العمق السوري تحديدا من
عفرين في ريف حلب عمرو حلبي ربما يسلط
الضوء على المشهد من هناك في بعد مرور
اكثر من اربعه ايام نحن نتحدث عن الساعه
المئه وما بعدها اليك الكلمه عنك
عبد السلام نحن كنا في الحقيقه متجهين الى
احد المواقع التي يعمل فيها الدفاع المدني
من اجل استخراج الانقاض واضعفهم من اجل
استخراج الجثث من تحت الانقاض في جنديرس
بريف حلب لكن في الطريق استوقفتنا هذه
المناظر واستوقفتنا هذه المشاهد لهؤلاء
الناس نحن كنا نخبركم في اللايفات السابقه
والمقابلات السابقه عن اناس يفترسون
الطرقات ويفترشون الاراضي بلا اي ماوى
والان سنحاول ان نقوم بتسليط الضوء عليهم
هنالك عشرات العوائل على مدى هذا الشارع
اكثر من اثنين كيلو متر عوائل يجلسون على
الارض بلا خيمه بلا ماوى اطفال صغار
يرتجفون من البرد ليس عندهم طعام ليس
عندهم ماء
احوالهم ورايناهم تحدثنا الى بعضهم صار
لهم اربعه ايام هنا في الشارع بلا ماوى
بلا نار حتى بعضهم ليس عنده نار او حطب
يقوم بالتدفئه يجلسون على هذه الارصفه لم
تاتي اليهم اي مساعدات ينامون في هذا
العراء في درجات حراره بارده جدا الان في
النهار هنالك برد شديد فما بالكم خلال
درجات الليل
هنالك بعض الناس حظوا بخيمه في هذه
المواقع لكن معظم الناس هنا
يبيتون على الارصفه دون اي مساعدات قد
قدمت اليهم والمنظر هنا في الحقيقه ماساوي
وكارثي للغايه هناك اطفال رايناهم يكون
وسنحاول ان نقرب لكم صوره اكثر فاكثر هذا
على الطرف الاخر كذلك نساء واطفال وعجائز
على الارصفه ليس لديهم خيم معظمهم فروا
ونزحوا من المدن التي تعرضت لهذا الزلزال
في شمال غربي سوريا في ريف حلب
تحدثنا الى بعضهم وسنحاول ان نقرب الصوره
اكثر ونتحدث ايضا مع بعض العائلات بيوتهم
اخبرونا بانها بعضهم مدمره والاخرى لم تعد
صالحه للسكن واخرون
خائفون ولا يريدون ان يذهبوا الى المنازل
خشيه الهزات الارتداديه التي لا تزال تضرب
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا
هؤلاء الناس عبد السلام مثلهم في مناطق
عديده في ريف حلب ينتشر مئات العوائل
حالهم كحال هؤلاء الناس هناك بعض المنظمات
المحليه التي جاءت الى هذه الاماكن ووزعت
بعض الخيام التي استطعت ان تقدمها لكن
القصه هي بانه لابد ان تكون هنالك مساعدات
دوليه اكبر حتى تستطيع ان تغطي احتياجات
الناس انظروا مثلا الى هذه العائله انا لا
اعرف حقيقه يعني نخجل ان نقوم بلقائهم
هناك كثيرون رفضوا لان حالهم يكفي وهو
صورتهم يعني
كافيه بنقل المشهد لكن سنحاول سنحاول ان
يعطيك العافيه اختي الحمد لله على السلامه
ممكن بس نسالكم عن وضعكم شو صار معكم
والله الحمد لله طلعنا بخير وسلامه الف
نعمه الحمد لله رب العالمين
كم ينصركم هون
الحمد لله رب العالمين صرنا اسبوع
من وقت ما صار الزلزال عم بتنام هون على
الرصيف
بتمنى ان شاء الله يا رب يحطوا بالبا
الحنيه ويجزيكم الخير مثلا خيام شيء الحمد
لله
الاولاد شلون شلون عم تجيبوا اكل شرب دفق
شو عم تعملوا
شو بتوجه رساله للمنظمات شو للناس اللي
بتسمعك
الله يحميكم
الحمد لله على سلامتكم
الله يسلمك يا رب محاولة ننتقل الى عائله
اخرى عبد السلام كما ترى هذا اطفال في
الشارع يعني منظر في الحقيقه هو كافي لان
يقوم لان يشرح حاله هؤلاء الاطفال